Remember that the totient of n, where n is the product of two primes,
is the totient of those two primes.
Multiplying this out, we get pq - (p + q) + 1.
Pq here is the same as n.
Now we know that p + q is equal to n - φ(n) - 1.
Now we're our goal is to show that if we know φ(n) we can easily find p.
If we can find p, we can easily find q.
What we want to do is find an equation for p - q that only uses n.
Then we'd be able to add these two, get rid of the q
and be able to solve for p as the sum of these two equations divided by 2.
That's our goal to get a solution for p - q that doesn't involve n.
Let's see if you can figure that out yourself.
I will give you a hint, which is to think about squaring p - q.